Hey folks, welcome to the cute woodland creatures
edition of my precon reviews. A plurality of my
patrons thought I should look at the group hug
precon, and in this video I’m going to accomplish
a simple set of tasks—I’m going to lay out what
I think the deck is trying to do, I’m going to
describe what I like about the deck, and finally
I’m going to talk about what I dislike about it,
and what changes I’d make to fix the things I
dislike. With that in mind, let’s jump right in.
The commander for this deck is the honorable Ms.
Bumbleflower, and the first thing I note here is
that her effect is quite cool and unique.
Just the line “Whenever you cast a spell,
target opponent draws a card” is wild—part of
what lets me consider this a group hug commander
of sorts is the sheer amount of value you can
give to opponents. There are general politics
commanders like Breena and 2023 Rocco that
passively offer opponents resources but have
a built-in way to twist things back in your favor,
but with Ms. Bumbleflower you’re actively handing
your opponents cards when you cast spells, and
if you don’t cast exactly two spells per turn,
she gives your opponents more cards than she gives
to you. The second spell clause gives you cards
when the ability triggers for the second time each
turn, and this really hones in the blue identity
of this card—you want to cast two spells per turn
unless you just love giving your opponents cards.
In the decklist, we can see a number of things
that fit with what this commander is doing—for
one, there are a fair number of decently chunky
beaters, most of which would enjoy being given
+1/+1 counters and flying. A lot of these utilize
+1/+1 counters in some way, and to go with this we
can see a handful of other cards with some sort
of counter synergies. In addition to the +1/+1
counter beats, there is some degree of giving
other players resources present, as you might
expect for a deck labeled “group hug”. There are 5
cards that utilize Bloomburrow’s “gift” mechanic,
where a spell can have an additional effect if an
opponent is offered some sort of resource. There
are also 11 other cards I’d describe as huggy
and 6 cards that are vaguely political in some
capacity, though the line between these categories
I’ve constructed is a bit fuzzy. There are also
other cards whose effects depend on the actions
of your opponents and you could argue that these
are political, though this deck is relatively
beatdown oriented so I’m not convinced it will
be easy to talk opponents into feeding these.
Results may vary, basically. It seems like this
deck is looking to gradually develop beaters and
value engines while currying favor with various
opponents, right up until it starts to snowball
out of control and can drop the friendly pretexts.
So, that’s the deck. But what do I think about
what this deck is doing? Well, I’ll start with
what I like, and there’s actually quite a lot of
that. This deck broadly has a decent card quality,
a focused enough plan to win, and good amounts
of different types of support cards. There are
several quite-decent-quality beaters, and
Ms. Bumbleflower is solid for purposes of
amplifying and pushing through damage for both
these and the cards that are more in the realm
of being support creatures. Side note—I find the
aesthetic contrast between Psychosis Crawler and
the rest of this deck very funny. The +1/+1
counter package of the deck, though not super
wide, has some real all-stars in it—there are
several different threats that grow over time,
and among the handful of counter synergy pieces,
Rishkar Peema Renegade is a pretty sweet ramp
tool and Kalonian Hydra is counter-pumping bomb
that will run away with games if left unchecked.
The deck will likely be able to politically
navigate through the game using its commander,
offering some opponents resources while beating
down others with its suite of growing threats.
As I mentioned earlier, the quantities of support
cards here are also quite decent. There are 14
cards I’d categorize as ramp and 15 cards I’d
categorize as draw, and these should prepare the
deck decently well to accelerate into a gameplan
and keep up momentum even if the deck hits some
setbacks. I playtested this deck a number of
times, and the average curve out that this deck
manages is far better than in either of the other
precons I’ve looked at—the deck is able to ramp,
build resources with the commander, and set
up value engines with quite a decent degree
of consistency. Obviously when I’m playtesting the
deck I’m kind of abstracting away the cards that
opponents are being given, and I like to think
this is reasonable enough. A lot of EDH games
will have one or two players who are lagging a bit
behind for one reason or another, and while giving
these players resources doesn’t necessarily come
at no cost, the gameplay cost will be lower than
the cost of giving all opponents resources.
For that reason I mostly think about this
resource donation as being probably not an issue
as long as this deck is meaningfully progressing
its own game plan at the same time. While you
could reasonably argue that this means the deck
should be held to a slightly higher bar than
some other precons in terms of how it plays,
it most likely passes even that bar as well—this
is just a deck that plays pretty smoothly. A big
part of this is likely the manabase—the manabase
of this deck is pretty similar to the manabase of
the Outlaws at Thunder Junction precon I looked
at a few months back, which is to say, it has a
healthy land count and a really robust amount of
color-fixing that results in quite healthy symbol
counts. Now, this isn’t at no cost—of the 38
lands, 9 always enter tapped and 7 sometimes do,
and I’d guess those two figures average out to
roughly a one-third tapland quantity. While this
is a bit higher than most players will want long
term, it’s far from a terrible starting point,
and this tapland density doesn’t feel particularly
bad in practice. In addition, in the lens of
considering this precon as a product, giving
players more fixing lands to work with is
undoubtedly a good thing, even if it means the
deck includes taplands that might later get cut.
Finally, this deck has an adequate amount of
ways to interact with things opponents are
doing. This deck has two counterspells, three
board wipes, five single target removal spells,
and a smattering of other cards that play other
related purposes such as slowing opponents,
defending against major attacks, and protecting
key pieces. Now, one of those categories I’ve
been historically less of a fan of—I find that
space dedicated to defensive spells would often
be better allocated on actual removal or on
things that push a player’s own gameplan. And
I will be cutting a couple defensive cards
from this deck—kind of. But this deck’s plan
of building up large, evasive threats means that
life total races won’t be an uncommon situation,
and having a fog around in that case might
be quite helpful. The deck’s political tools,
namely the commander, also give it a decent
option for negotiating with opponents,
and avoiding pressure if it seems worth the
price of an opponent having some cards. I can
see the appeal of this deck’s political and
defensive elements, and I imagine they work
decently in tandem with the deck’s more concrete
removal for keeping the game under control.
Alright, it’s time to get into what I dislike
about this precon, and also what I’d change to
help it out with those things. I mentioned that
the manabase of the deck reminds me of the OTJ
Gonti precon, and there’s one other way that this
precon reminds me of that one. In the video where
I reviewed the Gonti deck, I highlighted that
it feels like the decklist was designed to be
a generic theft deck rather than a semi-theft
deck tailored to what Gonti does. This precon
is similar in that it seems like Wizards of
the Coast added a bunch of group hug stuff to
this precon because the commander does something
vaguely group hug-y, but Ms. Bumbleflower is not
a generic group hug commander. No, Snail’s theory
of optimal Bumbleflower dictates that I want to
be sharing card draw with my weakest opponent,
maybe playing politics with it here and there,
and then also making optimal usage of the +1/+1
counters and flying that Ms. Bumbleflower gives
me. In addition, a lot of the group hug elements
currently in the deck don’t even feel like they
play that nicely with the rest of what the
deck is doing. Basically, what I dislike
about this deck is that it's a bit unfocused,
including lots of stuff that is outside what I
believe the deck wants to be—a high velocity,
politics-heavy +1/+1 counter beatdown deck.
Now, I understand if somebody wants to play
harder into the group hug elements, since
group-hug-ish precons don’t come often, but in
my mind there’s just not enough to work with here
for that. I will preserve the group hug element
on some level, though, in that I don’t feel the
need to prevent or take advantage of the cards
that Ms. Bumbleflower gives my opponents—they’re
allowed to have a little gift. Another thing
that might be nice is making the deck slightly
lower-curved to allow for double-spelling
with Ms. Bumbleflower earlier in the game,
as the current deck is a bit high curved for my
taste. Overall, I’m going to make 20 card swaps,
and all of these will be done with a
precon budget in mind, so I’m not going
to add anything over $3 and I’m going to try to
end up at a lower overall price for the deck.
With all that in mind, I’m going to start by
cutting some of the huggier elements of this
deck. I like the idea of extra land plays in this
deck, but I don’t really want my opponents to
have extra land plays if they’re gonna be getting
fed cards by me, so I choose to swap out Rites of
Flourishing for Wayward Swordtooth and Ghirapur
Orrery for Case of the Locked Hothouse. Case is
a really powerful card in general, and Swordtooth
is a nice option as a creature to give flying once
Ms. Bumbleflower is in play. I’m also choosing to
cut Tenuous Truce and Intellectual Offering—these
cards are doing something similar to what the
commander is doing, but the rate on cards per
mana just isn’t great on either of these.
Kwain and Selvala likewise get cut because I
like being able to choose which opponents get fed
cards—if one of my opponents is ahead, I want to
be able to avoid giving them extra resources
while still being able to utilize my cards.
Another type of card I choose to cut is cards
that cost too much mana, since I’m trying to
drop the mana curve. Octomancer is a funny card,
but this isn’t really a token deck and five mana
is just too much to pay for some vanilla stats.
Another cut is Coveted Jewel—it’s a funny card,
but this deck doesn’t have enough ways
of preventing opponents from snagging it,
and when it does get taken they don’t even need
to pay that expensive 6 mana up front like I did.
Most other cuts I made were cards that just
don’t do enough. Bloodroot Apothecary, though
it’s pre-selling for upwards of $10, seems highly
mediocre to me as anti-treasure tech—opponents
can still afford to crack a few treasures at a
table without other poison, and then the rest
can be saved for after the apothecary is off the
board. I’ll take a Manglehorn over this any day
of the week. Now, a cut that truly pains me is
Jolly Gerbils—this card is extremely cute, but
the deck simply doesn’t have enough gift cards to
justify its inclusion, and even if I added a few
more I’m still not convinced it’d be preferable
to a better two drop. Another cut is Hoofprints
of the Stag—this is a decent incremental value
piece if it’s played early, but it’s a very dead
draw later in the game. Triskaedekaphile is
another card I opted to cut—this deck wants
some number of no maximum hand size cards, but
the deck already has several other ones and this
card just doesn’t offer enough outside of
that to warrant keeping it in my opinion.
What goes in in place of these cards?
Beyond the replacements I already mentioned,
a big area is +1/+1 counter synergies. A
lot of these are reasonably basic—Conclave
Mentor is a bear that amplifies counters, Dusk
Legion Duelist is a bear that’s a draw engine,
Benthic Biomancer is a similar card for one mana
that loots instead, and Kami of the Whispered
Hopes is just a fantastic card, well worth the
$2 or so price tag. A couple others I picked
out that likewise offer a bit of ramp
were Incubation Druid and Freestrider
Lookout, both solid ramp options. Importantly,
I tried to pick out stuff that’s good in general
and relatively low-cost. The issue with picking
out big, fancy payoff cards is that opponents
can just deny your commander with removal, and
then suddenly you invested heavily in something
that can’t actually materialize. Kami and
Druid in particular are especially great
because without the commander they’re still
mana dorks, but with even a single targeting
with Ms. Bumbleflower’s ability either of
them can suddenly tap for three whole mana,
and Kami only goes up from there. There are also
a few more specific cards from Modern Horizons 3
that I added, as that was a fantastic set for
+1/+1 counter synergies. Dreamtide Whale is a
card that feels like it was made for this deck—it
proliferates +1/+1 counters, it has a high power
for delivering flying beats, and this is a deck
that wants to double-spell anyway so the whale
should be sticking around. Evolution Witness is
another pretty sweet card—it’s not going to be
wildly powerful in the early game, but later
in the game it can be an unstoppable torrent
of value. The third card from this set I added is
Envoy of the Ancestors, and this is my answer to
the question of defensive cards and life total
races—just gain some life! This card sets up a
player for a truly impressive quantity of
lifegain, which will help when facing off
against the final player and needing to survive
long enough to get the necessary attacks in.
Beyond these, I also tweaked the interaction suite
a bit. I added Negate as a nice general-purpose
counterspell to help with avoiding board wipes,
and I also swapped out Perplexing Test for a
slightly weirder five mana instant—Brokers
Confluence. This is a fun package for this
deck—it can shut off a problematic ability, it
can protect our board without losing the counters,
and it can also serve as a sort of overrun-type
card if we’re going in for the kill—you can always
just Proliferate Proliferate Proliferate. Finally,
I also tweaked the manabase to have more green
mana, since I just cut a bunch of blue and white
cards and added a bunch of green ones. Overall,
this precon was quite solid, and I actually
considered changing fewer than my usual 20 cards
for this deck considering that. You could probably
drop the number of changes to 10 and still have
a quite decent +1/+1 counter-based upgraded
precon, but I just felt like taking it all
the way with my changes. I didn’t talk about this
earlier beyond gesturing at the fact that tables
will often have a player or two lagging behind,
but I imagine the sort of selective hug effect
seen on Ms. Bumbleflower is likely an enjoyable
addition for a lot of tables. My issue with
symmetrical group hug is that, though it means
everybody’s deck gets to do something, it often
also means that the player who was getting ahead
anyway gets to have even more advantage. This more
selective method of resource-giving, on the other
hand, can theoretically lead to more dynamic games
with different players on a more equal footing.
To anybody who has played with this precon or this
commander in general, let me know if this was
your experience, because I’m kind of curious.
Thanks for watching! If you like what
I make here and want some more of it,
you can support me over on Patreon.
Recently I got a new camera lens,
and I’ve started recording less-scripted facecam
videos for ideas and thoughts that I’ve had but
that haven’t quite made their way into an actual
video on the channel, and posting said videos on
Patreon. One that I released a day or so
ago included random thoughts about some
various Bloomburrow cards. If that sounds
up your alley, link is in the description.